There are two models that examine the role of stress in relation to our health.
One is the Physiological Reactivity Model, which attempts to explain the causal
role of stress-related bodily changes in illness. The second model is called
the Health Behavior Approach. Here the explanation for illness or health is
focused on the role of behaviors such as diet, exercise, and substance abuse.
We already discussed how diet, exercise, and substance abuse are ways of coping
with stress, so we won't say much more about the health behavior approach.
However, let's talk about the physiological reactivity model. So let's take
this example, let's say you walk in the class and the professor says, put your
books away, take out a piece of paper, we're having a test. Hearing this
statement from your professor may cause stress. The fact that you're not
prepared for the pop quiz results in a stressful response. However, if you have
read the material and studied, hearing the professor say put your notes away
and get out a sheet of paper may not result in a stressful response. So here we
have an event, which is the pop quiz, and then your appraisal of the situation.
And this, is what's really important here. You may appraise a situation in a
positive and beneficial way which produces positive emotions. However on the
other hand you may see the situation as negative or even potentially
threatening and that produces negative emotions. From here the negative
emotions causes the stress response. Which you can recall is the activation of
the sympathetic nervous system. However, prolonged exposure to the stressful
situation causes extended release of cortisol and sustained activation of the
sympathetic nervous system which in turn weakens the body. As we discussed
earlier the body is negatively effected by the suppression of the immune system
which increases our succeptability to illness. Now one factor we did not
discuss was that prolong exposure to activation of the sympathetic nervous
system also has negative consequences on our cardiovascular health.